[Musique]
tout de suite retrouver l'actualité de
la semaine retour en image sur les
principaux événements du
département la charte agricole de
sainte-susanne a été signée entre la
commune le département l'État et la
Chambre d'Agriculture un document qui
définit les orientations stratégiqu pour
le maintien et l'évolution des activités
agricoles sur l'ensemble du territoire
de la commune pour les 15 prochaines
années c'est la maison des producteurs
c'est le pôle de recherche qu'on
souhaiterait également faire dans les
EAU DE saintesusanne c'est le
développement de notre ce qu'on appelle
la route des haau on pourrait développer
également ce qu'on appelle le
l'agrotouristique et en particulier des
a piquniqu et tout il s'agit avant tout
de maintenir le potentiel productif
agricole de développer des filière
d'optimiser une agriculture raisonnée de
structurer l'écoulement des produits et
maintenir une filière canne
compétitive nous allons donc pouvoir
accompagner la commune sur des
dispositifs européens que nous gérons au
tite de l'autorité de gestion par
exemple accompagner la commune de
saint-susan dans le financement de
voiries agricole en direction des
exploitant agricole nous avons également
cette volonté de pouvoir accompagner la
ville de sainte-susan dans la maîtrise
du foncier agricole dans la protection
de ces terrain le défi à relever pour
les 15 années à venir sera de contenir
le développement de l'urbanisme tout en
préservant le foncier
[Musique]
agricole 17 porteurs et donc trois
Joelettes avec une personne à mobilité
réduite de l'association run Andy move
ont participé au 10 km seminocturnes de
La Possession c'est la première fois que
10 km non mais c'est toujours trop court
parce que les qu'on a dans ce moment là
c'est une unique donc c'est toujours des
moments qui sont trop courts organisé
par l'association sport loisir Océan
Indien et Andy basket de la possession
cette course mélange valide et non
valide sur un même parcours de 9 km
urbains donc déjà c'est un défi sportif
et puis le fait de pouvoir emmener ces
personnes handicapées c'est ils savent
qu'ils font plaisir à toutes ces
personnes soutenu par le Conseil
départemental cette manifestation a duré
une bonne partie de la soirée sur la
place du
festival c'est un plaisir de voir autant
de monde en fauteuil participer à ce
genre de course comme disait pierre de
certin le principal c'est de participer
voilà tout simplement et de prendre du
plaisir sportivement c'est un grand
sportif qui gagne ce 10 km François
Lebon boucle l'épreuve en 32 minutes
5 un bel exploit noyé dans une autre
performance celle d'apporter autant de
bonheur à autant de public en même
temps passation de commandement de la 5e
compagnie de formation professionnel
entre le capitaine Tiffanie gral et le
capitaine Jean-Pierre bonizoni le 28
juillet au jardin de l'État à
Saint-Denis j'étais responsable de du
bon déroulement de la formation
professionnelle au sein de la 5e
compagnie qui est situé àr
à Saint-Denis maintenant je vais partir
vers d'autres vers d'autres horizons à
Paris et poursuivre ma scolarité ça fait
un évidemment un pincement au cœur
puisque je quitte un métier je
quitte des gens voilà et je quitte une
île aussi voilà donc ça rend triste le
capitaine bonizoni passe donc à la tête
d'une des plus importantes unités du
RSMA basé au quartier lray à
Saint-Denis j'espère y apporter euh
ma contribution pour l'emploi des des
jeunes réunionnés en les en arrivant les
insérer au mieux dans dans la vie active
réunionnaise ou voir en métropole une
première pour cet équipement du
département qui n'avait encore jamais
accueilli une passation de
commandement fin des travaux sur la
départementale 26 entre Pierrefond et
bois Deol c'est très important
d'aménager cette partie sud notamment de
Pierrefond qui est un point stratégique
par rapport à la circulation en heur
d'affluence et par jour c'est 20000
véhicules qui passent sur cette route
entre
Pierrefond Ravine des cabri bois d'olive
et les autres villes avisinantes
l'aménagement consiste à améliorer et à
sécuriser les accès à la civice et aux
différents services ainsi que le
cheminement des piétons sur ce secteur
sur tout le département le budget route
a été doublé sur cette mandature je
pense que
ce projet de mandature sur les routes la
la la réflection des des radiers est
vraiment très utile ce projet de
réaménagement n'est qu'un début dans le
sud l'objectif étant en partie de
sécuriser les routes départementales de
plus en plus
[Musique]
fréquenté le musée du sel et le
département organisent des journées
ludiques pour les enfants lors des
vacances scolaires l'objectif étant que
les parents accompagnent leur enfant et
découvrent ensemble cet équipement
culturel unique à la Réunion on met en
place des
ateliers artistiques des dessins en
pastel sec des du modelage avec de la
pâte à sel des
ateliers pour thème le goût et des
ateliers compte ces ateliers sont en
rapport avec les baleines en partie
puisque à cette période ils viennent au
plus près de nos côtes vous du chocolat
alors c'était un atelier qui était
proposé et qui nous paraissait très
alléchant voilà cuisiner fabriquer son
chocolat à la fleur de sel l'objectif
pour les enfants ben c'est de venir au
musée du sel bien sûr voir comment
fonctionnent les salines de la pote au
sel et donc découvrir la fleur de sel
pour connaître les secrets qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire les différentes
utilisations de la fleur de sel
fabriquer une baleine en dessin et à
faire une Bale une baleine en en pâte à
sel ben jeis venu faire du chocolat
salé avec des graines de cacao j'aime
bien ici parce que c'est pas souvent
qu'on voit du sel ben du sel propre quoi
voilà naturel acteur majeur de
l'animation touristique à la Réunion le
Département souhaite élargir son
programme et augmenter les ateliers
proposés au musée du sel à toutes les
vacances du calendrier
[Musique]
scolaire